the outcome of these talks could
determine if president putin decides to
invade ukrainian forces are doing
exercises of their own right now but
they would be vastly outgunned if russia
were to attack holly williams is in key
for us holly good morning
good morning this is the u.s embassy
here in kiev from where all american
personnel will be withdrawn in the next
48 hours according to our sources
meanwhile ukraine's government continues
to urge calm and life goes on here
pretty much as normal but make no
mistake people are worried
a farmer's market on kiev's john mccain
street the late senator is loved in this
country in part because he pushed
america to send weapons to ukraine a
russian invasion could cause up to a
hundred thousand civilian casualties
according to u.s officials these are the
people in the firing line we just
live in the moment and that's all
alina kombucha is a fitness instructor
who says nearly eight years of russian
aggression has made ukrainians immune to
panic we don't know what will be
because
this is not our decisions
and we don't want war
ukraine is now close to being encircled
by russian forces
and there's fear these intimidating
military drills are a prelude to the
russians moving in
it's thought an invasion could start
with airstrikes
kiev's subway system also serves as the
ukrainian capital's biggest bomb shelter
the government of kiev says it has an
evacuation plan as well as preparations
for maintaining electricity heating and
communications in case of an attack
back on john mccain street constantine
belotzerkiewski told us he already has
an emergency bag packed in case he has
to run from a russian attack the worst
thing is
you feel helpless you know so
it's just a matter of is it happen or
not and that's it the only thing you can
do is wait
demanding an urgent meeting with russia
in the next 48 hours but says moscow's
ignored its request to explain why it's
massed roughly a hundred thousand troops
on ukraine's border tony
hillary williams in ukraine for us holly
thank you very much